we never imagined in a million years
we'd have to start the show like this
never never never never never never
Grammy Awards host Alicia Keys kicked
off Sunday ceremony acknowledging the
tragic passing of Kobe Bryant we're all
feeling crazy sadness right now because
earlier today Los Angeles America and a
whole wide world
lost a hero earlier in the day news
broke that the former NBA legend and his
13 year old daughter Gianna died in a
helicopter crash just outside of Los
Angeles or literally standing here
heartbroken in the house that Kobe
Bryant built
and there wasn't a dry eye in the
Staples Center after Keyes saying a
tribute to the late 8th lete alongside
boys to men
[Music]
et caught up with boys to men backstage
after the emotional performance this is
a very very tough day how did this come
together in about ten minutes we got the
phone call that Alisha wanted to do this
special tribute unfortunate tribute for
Kobe we've obviously you know
coincidentally we were on the show
anyway so called us up which cooked up
the arrangement real quick and we did
what we did out there what was it like
going out there knowing that you're
inside the building that was Kobe's home
I mean it'sit's an honor as well as the
tragedy you know to know that he used to
you know come back and forth to the
games and you know that he won't be here
any longer his spirit is still gonna
dwell within these buildings without
doubt in this building and it's just
gonna be one of those things that he's
gonna be remembered as one of the
greatest that ever did it as for keys
we love you Kobe she reminded the crowd
about the healing power of music we're
gonna do what we're here to do I know
that we're gonna all join together and
do what we doing happy times and
challenging times we're gonna sing
together we're gonna laugh together
we're gonna dance together we're gonna
cry together we're gonna bring it all
together we're gonna love together and
we're gonna make sure that we are
celebrating the most powerful energy the
most beautiful thing in the world the
one thing that has the power to bring
all of us together and as music
[Music]
you